noah  you're gonna be late  listen i was thinking we could do family  night tonight  movie dinner  okay i'm going for a run  [Music]  uh  marion county has been placed on  lockdown due to an ongoing incident  i'm five miles from home i don't have a  car and tell me what's happening  there are five people barricaded your  son is one of them and so is the suspect  are negotiators in contact he doesn't  have your negotiator son does he he has  mine and an ar-15 do something about it  noah  where are you  who's here  i'm scared  pull up the internal drives  that's illegal amy he has my boy i need  his phone number i'm coming to get you  honey  he's a good kid  mrs carr this is  no i'm not the police  [Music]  you